hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on Luke universe calm thank
you and enjoy so now we've got IDL
intermediate density lipoprotein and
they're basically VLDL remnants VLDL
remnants and they can be acted upon by
an enzyme called hepatic triglyceride
lipase which converts the IDL into LDL
hence the reason why the ideals function
is basically being an LDL precursor okay
so it's an LDL precursor basically
that's one of its main roles is to give
rise to LDL another thing that it does
is it returns some of the endogenous
lipids to the liver and its main April
proteins are be 100 and II
so it doesn't have c2 like VLDL did and
the reason why is because CL to the c2
on the VLDL was lost when c2 activated
the the lipoprotein lipase as we saw
previously right here
right so basically we left off right
here where IDL was made as a remnant
from the VLDL and it no longer has a c2
because it was lost here when the c2
activated lipoprotein lipase so now I do
basically can do two things it can
either take I can either go back to the
liver be taken up by the apoE receptor
or by the LDL receptor so I guess we can
extend this line out to this way okay
and it can be taken up and then all that
components can be recycled or it can
give rise to LDL via HTTP attic
triglyceride life
a switch will digest the ideal to LDL
which actually gets rid of the apoE
protein and we we have LDL which is
talked about in the next video so this
video is kind of short because IDL's
pretty much just a precursor hope that
video is helpful thank you for watching
thanks for watching be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and don't forget to
share the video of anyone who you think
might find it helpful thanks and happy
studying